juste après le mariage
nous partons à paris un tel mariage le
votre chéri
en bresse à moi d'accord
non pas comme ça ce n'est pas grave
thérèse tué son ange gardien c'est notre
nuit de noces je suis trop fatigué terra
mair j'ai une surprise pour vous vous
vous souvenez de laurent a su petit ça
peut rester n'est ce pas avec plaisir
mon premier modèle était sourd comme un
pot mais son corps me parlait je
caressais l'intérieur de sa cuisse avec
mon pinceau les scores que disent et ils
caressent mois encore on enlève ton
choisi
je fume encore pire tenté par m tu me
cache des choses
si seulement ils disparaissaient
pourquoi disparaître est il un accident
est si vite arrivé c'était partout peut
être ou toi
thérèse c'est votre tour elle n'a l'air
de rien mais elle cache bien son jeu